this morning just this is a weird story  the investigation in carson city taking  place after a family was found living  inside a children's museum it's very  strange the carson city sheriff's  department made this discovery nearby  businesses had reported unsupervised  children roaming around the museum the  youngest  two years old  officers did return back to their  children's museum they were able to  retrieve several guns  very high concern of ours silencers  as well as some some drug and disha  there's no excuse for for what what took  place there are services available  especially in every community for the  children  authorities arrested this man the  museum's janitor 41 year old wilbert  calhoun the children's mother who is the  museum's manager was fired